i got a very broad charge about
tonight's
speech so
i decided i would just
try to talk from the heart
about my passions for some of them
anyway
sarah i do pick up on your thought and
open my remarks with the following
thought for your consideration
regret
for what you have done
is tempered by time
regret for what you have not done
is inconsolable
i want to meet you where you are this
evening
and since i know that at least some of
you are in sponge mode
meaning i'm about to leave this place
and what can i soak up
i'll try to give you some insights
about entrepreneurship
and some other subjects
may i start with a question
what matters
since i know in a general only in a
general sense what each of you cares
about
i trusted in offering
some of my personal thoughts a few of
them may resonate with some of you and
help you in your thinking as you look
ahead
i decided to focus
on what i think constitutes meaning in
one's professional life
so i leave such personal subjects as the
centrality of nurturing
and being in a loving relationship
for another forum
i've developed several needs that i
think together constitute what matters
to me
though i don't come from a particularly
advantaged childhood in a material sense
i was blessed with parents and
grandparents who constantly espoused
basic values
of ethical behavior and fair dealing
and from them my my first need has
become to act in a responsible way to be
ethical in my dealings
with people and to really
stand for something
though i have fallen short on many
occasions and continue to do so
i still strive toward the mark
for the prize of high calling
i've always had a need as well to push
my capabilities to grow not only
intellectually but in the exercise of
good judgment
like most of us i also seek recognition
from my peers
and from others who matter
next as i was able to move into
management positions i developed a
strong desire to teach
and to inspire those who worked with and
for me
that fundamental need to give back
although put on the back burner for many
years as i strove to carve out a career
did resurface in spades
and finally
the need for professional freedom
that is having some time
and some resources
to be able to choose where to apply
one's energies
i love the following phrase
whose author i do not know
work like you don't need the money
love like you've never been hurt
and dance like nobody's watching
i'll try to touch on these various needs
as i talk a little bit about
entrepreneurship and then move on to
some more general topics
these are indeed extraordinary times
the recent downturn notwithstanding the
buoyant u.s economy has created a sense
of prosperity that has touched
every segment of the working population
as most of you know in the heavy
manufacturing sector
there has been a net loss of jobs over
the past 25 years
yet our economy
is generally vibrant less so in the last
18 months of course and new jobs are
being created every year
those
jobs largely arise
from entrepreneurial efforts
they arise because
individuals had visions
and they pursued those visions
and people in the marketplace were
willing to buy the products and services
flowing from those visions
yet
most of us feel
we're destined to become observers
highly paid corporate managers
sitting just outside this wave of
entrepreneurialism
many of us have hoped
that someday we might become
entrepreneurs yet statistically most gsb
graduates
do not become entrepreneurs
fewer than 25 percent of our graduates
25 years out according to the data we
have classify themselves
as having undertaken something
entrepreneurial
or been self-employed
yet some 90 percent of entering
first-year mbas
express a strong interest in owning
their own businesses
what happens
to derail these ambitions
well
reality intervenes
how can i worry about being my own boss
i'm concerned with getting a good job
these days
having a life of some kind and paying
off the huge student loans i'm behind
i understand
believe me i understand
i offer for your consideration
two of my very favorite
quotes
they describe sharply contrasting
attitudes which are likely to lead one
into very different careers
and indeed
lives
the first is from t s eliot's classic
proof rock
no
i am not prince hamlet nor was meant to
be
i am an attendant lord
one that will do to swell a progress
start a scene or two
advise the prince
no doubt an easy tool
deferential
glad to be of use
politic
cautious
and meticulous
full of high sentence
but a bit obtuse
at times indeed almost ridiculous
almost at times the fool
i grow old
i shall wear the bottoms of my trousers
rolled
shall i part my hair behind do i dare to
eat a peach
i shall wear white flannel trousers and
walk upon the beach
i have heard the mermaids singing each
to
each i do not think that they will sing
to me
i have seen the moment of my greatness
flicker
and i have seen the eternal foot man
hold my coat
and snicker
and in short
i was afraid
end quote
penetrating words indeed
an attendant lord advising the prince
deferential
politic cautious
meticulous
glad to be of use
afraid
a sad portrayal indeed
in contrast hear these words of w.h
murray
which i've quoted in my class
he is the man who led the scottish
himalayan expedition
until one is committed there is
hesitancy
the chance to draw back
always in effectiveness
all acts of initiative and creation
there is one elementary truth the
ignorance of which kills countless ideas
and splendid plans
that the moment one commits oneself
then providence moves too
all sorts of things occur to help one
that would never otherwise have happened
a whole stream of events issues from the
decision
raising in one's favor all manner of
unforeseen incidents and meetings and
material assistance which no man could
have dreamt would have come his way
i have learned a deep respect
for one of goethe's couplets
whatever you can do
or dream you can
begin it
boldness
has
genius power
and magic in it
end quote
so perhaps it's some it's time for some
questions
a good one might be as i near the end of
my nba experience
how would i become an entrepreneur
if i wanted to
are they born like 300 hitters in
baseball
can they be made
well before we talk about
characteristics of entrepreneurs i'd
like to identify one thing that you
should not bring
if you aspire to own your own business
don't bring capital
don't bring money you say
how can capital be anything other than
an advantage to a would-be entrepreneur
well one of the things that we teach is
that the functions of the entrepreneur
and the capital supplier
are very different
nowhere is it written that the
entrepreneur needs to supply capital
the disadvantage of having capital is
that one tends to define the scope of
one's venture according to the size of
one's pocketbook
now our working definition of
entrepreneurship is the pursuit of
opportunity without regard
to the resources currently controlled
now if you think you might want to own
your own company
match your outlook with five attitudes
that we've observed
in most entrepreneurs one
an unending dissatisfaction with the
status quo
and that has two elements
you're not happy with the status quo
your status quo and you think you can do
something better
you think you can do something better
than it is now being done
and find a better place to sow your
seeds
to a healthy self-confidence a
willingness to be lonely
to make tough decisions to stand on a
level of the organization chart with no
peers
and to have the bucks stop with you
three what i would call
responsible competence
that you feel good at what you do
that you think you can do more
and you're willing to stretch
for a concern for detail
there are very few successful
entrepreneurs i have ever seen who are
broad brush people in all aspects of
their professional life
they may be broad brush in some areas
but in matters that are critical to
success
they are meticulous
and if they are not meticulous by nature
they are astute enough to find a partner
who is so that if they cut the grass
somebody will pick up the clippings
five and finally perhaps most
importantly
a tolerance for ambiguity
that should not be confused with a love
of risk
because the best entrepreneurs i know
are constantly asking themselves how to
risk how to shrink risk out of a
situation
it does mean a willingness to
accept an uncertain future
you're not sure that you have a job
tomorrow you're not sure that you have
an income tomorrow
and you're willing to give up the
corporate and corporate environment
which you know
the peer group with which you feel
reasonably comfortable
the customer base the daily routines
and you'll take on the ambiguity
of attempting to establish in the
marketplace
your vision
of a venture
okay you've matched up your attitudes
with those that i've just described
and you pass maybe not a perfect match
but pretty good
how would you begin to become an
entrepreneur
how does one get
from here to there
from
employment to self-employment
i don't have an idea you say
i don't have money which you've told me
is an advantage
and i just don't know how
or where to start
i have to pay off my debts
i have
or i hope to soon have family
obligations
well
don't be afraid to take a big step if
one is indicated
you can't cross a chasm in two jumps
there is only one basic requirement in
terms of the process
that is
to figure out how to buy yourself some
time to be able to establish yourself
apart from your present
job so that
excuse me so that you can use the
morning of your energies on your new
venture
because if you're going to work full
time and have family responsibilities
and want to have any life outside your
professional endeavors you're only going
to be able to give the
evening of your energies to your new
venture if you remain employed
and new
ventures
demand morning efforts first class
enthusiasm alertness
so you need to be able to leave your
present position and live for some
period of time while you translate your
dream into reality
we think of entrepreneurship not just as
starting companies
or buying companies
or
managing growing companies
entrepreneurship
being aggressive and creative in
managing non-profits
rather
we think that the important differences
between an entrepreneur
and a trustee or an administrator
are attitudinal
that the entrepreneur is opportunity
driven the administrator tends to be
resource driven
saying
these are the resources these are the
assets under my trusteeship i should
protect them
we believe that the entrepreneur is
willing to
rent resources
while the administrator wants to own
them
has to own them
we think that a dissatisfaction with a
status quo is often what impels an
entrepreneur where the administrator
even a forward-looking one
is often thinking in terms of
evolutionary developments
of how he or she can improve the current
situation
at the margin
i hold firmly the belief
that entrepreneurship is a reasonable
career alternative not for all
but for any single person who might
choose it
you don't need to be impulsive
headstrong
bombastic
or flamboyant
you don't need to check your analytical
skills at the door
you need no operating experience
though it usually helps
to be an entrepreneur there are no
external barriers
only those
we internally impose
it is not because things are difficult
that we do not dare
it is because we do not dare
that things are difficult
those words from seneca
jfk reminded us
of the same thought in different words
we should not let our fears hold us back
from pursuing our hopes
a principle issue for you and charting
your career path is
will i be in someone else's company or
companies or in my own it's as basic as
that
in this decision our greatest foes
whom we must chiefly combat
are within
let's examine the moment for the for a
moment the risks
of employment
you know we're always examining the
risks of going out on our own
and they look formidable
let's think about the risks we run
by not going out on our own
while the company that employs you will
hopefully
challenge you
promote you
pay you well flatter you
give you increasing numbers of buttons
to push people to manage
it may also if you're lucky
acclimate you to its culture
envelope you and consume your
entrepreneurial energies perspective and
risk capacity
and i say perversely if you're lucky
because if you choose that path you want
to be
wrapped up in it that's the only way you
will do the best possible job
what a paradox
many although certainly not all larger
company executives
i submit
are anything but free
how many of them would love to leave
but don't know how to
don't know where to go
can't afford it
and in many cases don't dare to
i've rarely met an unhappy successful
entrepreneur but i've met many unhappy
successful executives of large companies
and partners of consulting and banking
firms
i submit that your career should not
only be fun
it should serve your life
in effect we've just described a few of
the risks of
not following the entrepreneurial path
tilling their soil
in their many locations
creating further value for their
shareholders
and when
asked you move
or you move on
indeed someone else's company versus
your own is more than a matter of how
you will spend your work days it will
reverberate to every facet of your life
and yet the decision to become an
entrepreneur is made even more difficult
because each of you labors under the
burden of high expectations
of close friends
of family
of yourselves
and with each success in your career
there are more chips on the table
with each victory come greater
expectations
and in order not to disappoint others or
oneself
a safer
more customary
lower risk career course is often
charted
but now we see
that there is no absolute safety
that risk
cannot be avoided
or as clint eastwood said in the movie
the rookie
you want a guarantee
by a toaster
we see that
now there is no
right
career choice
as there has been in the past
it was easy to choose a college or
university from the attractive
alternatives that each of you had
it was easy to choose a job
it was easy to choose a business school
from among the most prestigious
but now
there's no right choice
there's no low risk choice
there's no proper choice
most of us realize this fact
intellectually
but we find it very hard to accept
emotionally
certain risks in fact must be assumed as
mentioned consciously or not
and thus the operable question becomes
what set of risks can i best control
one of the reasons i didn't go into
academia there were a number
i didn't think i'd be good at
pure research
i needed to make more money but one of
the really compelling risks
for me
was that i perceived it to be an
environment with strong political
overtones
and that equated to me even at that
point in time i happen to think in this
way
that equated to me
to a set of risks i couldn't control
it's really hard to evaluate pure
research
and there's a strong political element
among tenure within the academy
i don't mean to demean anything at all
i'm just speaking from the heart
i start with the premise
that one of our goals in life
should be to die young
as late as possible
therefore what are the sum what are some
of the important questions to be asking
oneself if the door to an
entrepreneurial career is to be left
open
one
how would i define my ideal work
environment
in terms of partners
ambiguity
risks
peers
status
power
smaller versus larger work environment
structured versus unstructured
the importance of money
two
what skills of mine need supplementing
and to a do i think of supplementing
these skills by recruiting a partner
or by making myself more ready to go it
alone
good question there three
regarding the jobs now offered or
potentially available to me let's take a
look at the daily routine i would follow
the avenues of advancement
the availability of a mentor and two
very important things
what doors are opened or closed in my
career path by assuming this job
in other words what are the natural
transitions out of this job
and what are the more awkward
transitions
and secondly
in this job
how hard will it be for me to keep my
perspective
to keep my
career goal in mind and nurture it and
move toward it
i've learned that the easier a change is
to make the less it usually matters
and that the older we get the harder it
is to choose change which makes it even
more necessary to do so from time to
time
change is a form of hope
to risk change
is to believe in tomorrow
and hope is a gift we need
so i feel it behooves us to set a course
whereby each job change we make however
difficult
moves us closer to our career objective
but the
path must be visualized in advance
now back to the question of how to get
from here to there
well
the most difficult part of the task
as plato once said
quote
is the beginning of the work
end quote
and that means beginning the search
and sustaining the search for one's
entrepreneurial venture be it a startup
or a buyout
and maintaining a search is like
in some respects like maintaining
religious beliefs
they die if they're not nurtured
if you don't freshen that search
mentality by reading
by staying in touch with other aspiring
entrepreneurs and those who are actually
entrepreneuring
atrophy will set in
and the quest for one's venture will
soon be abandoned as
that naive idea i had back when i was at
the gsb
how does one prepare for an
entrepreneurial career
well there are alternative approaches
one industry specific experience if you
have a clear idea what industry you want
to go into which is rare
but sometimes happens
two
general management experience
operating experience or
line experience is desirable
and i feel that such supervisory skills
are broadly transferable
managing others is the key here
doing it on someone else's nickel before
you do it on your own because there's a
learning curve
three
assuming a sentry position
century position
where one can see the world of deal
opportunities going by that is being at
the intersection
of opportunities
capital
and management
some examples of sentry positions would
be small business consulting
bank workout departments
working for a small regional investment
bank or small venture capital or lbo
firm
even a cpa firm whose clients are
primarily smaller businesses
and the above three approaches are not
necessarily mutually exclusive
one of the really important by words
is don't spend five years getting two
years experience
though you're eager to leave stanford
now to get going
at least part of you is
you'll never again have a comparable
chance
to reflect
and to set goals working goals
as you'll have in the next six weeks
don't allow the urgent
to preempt the important
in your daily lives set aside time to
think about what's important
use those goals
move toward them on a daily and weekly
basis
modify them as needed compare your
progress against them from time to time
and remember
choose carefully
because with the talent each of you has
whatever you really want
you'll probably get
the next few years are key you require
alternatives to be in a strong position
to make good decisions
and you it's helpful to look at a lot of
opportunities in order to refine your
judgment
what are the risks of the
entrepreneurial path
you won't eat
no that's really not a risk
you can figure out a way to eat
failure
perhaps
but in the event of failure do you lose
your reputation
i certainly hope not no need to
do you lose your own money
no
do you lose other people's money yep
but they are risk investors
so that's okay
they expect to have some losses
a company won't hire you after a failure
wrong
the biggest risk
is that you may become
constitutionally unemployable
you may decide that you can't work for
anyone else
yet you failed in your own venture so
you may have to go back and re-establish
your credentials working for somebody
else
as unappealing as it is
in order to try again
i want to take just a moment to talk
about a phenomenon that has arisen in in
fairly recent years
the so-called search fund with which
many of you are familiar some are not
back in the mid 80s there were two or
three individuals who upon receiving
their mbas got a small group of backers
to support them in looking for a company
to buy
and as it happened those two or three
individuals were successful both in
getting backers and buying companies
and i think by 1990 there were only
three or four or five out there
who had done this
however that so-called search fund model
getting funded to look around for a
company to buy
has gained a head of steam
to the point where something
well over 35 individuals or pairs of
recent mbas have raised funds of several
hundred thousand dollars a piece
immediately or soon after graduation and
most of them but not all have bought
companies
there are still a few of them who have
raised search funds and have not bought
companies
there have been a few others who
failed to find a company to buy and had
to go back and get a job
but the vast majority
have succeeded
some dramatically
so there is a small but rather
extraordinary record that is being
compiled
it doesn't represent a sample of
substantial enough
size to be statistically significant but
it's anecdotally interesting because
these individuals did not have any
operating experience at all with only a
few exceptions
generally did
they'd never run anything they'd never
managed anyone
the idea was to look for a company that
was simple
that did not have a big product
development cycle
or a big technology component or a big
style component did not have multiple
locations was profitable at the time it
was acquired
was of a reasonable size that is say
five to twenty million in sales
and it would be financed conservatively
and a board of directors would be
assembled
it could be active advisors for the
entrepreneur
so the concept was to make up for that
lack of operating experience of the
individual mba graduate by finding the
profitable company financing it
conservatively with a strong board of
advisors
in other words
the image is
here's an existing horse
going around the track
with a jockey on it
that's the successful company now making
money and we're simply going to change
jockeys
and put the mba on the horse to replace
the selling owner
with the instructions for the first 12
to 18 months
just try not to let the horse fall down
or bump into the railings
and then when he or she the new mba ceo
has a little bit of operating experience
and familia familiarity with the
business
then
start making changes
it's become quite an interesting
phenomenon one that i've supported
and as you can tell i'm enthusiastic
about
i think it bears watching because it's
the most direct way that i know of
for aspiring mba entrepreneurs to get
into business for themselves without
taking several years in grade to get
operating experience that we heretofore
thought they needed
very important in this effort have been
different groups of our alumni and
others as well of course but these
people have often mentored our mbas as
friends
investors board members and formal
advisors
and now that there are well over 35
search funders out there
there are those those who have gone
earlier in the process
are turning to advising and helping
those who are coming along after them
so that we hope the model
becomes self-perpetuating
and really our objectives
are not only self-perpetuation but to
have the search fund model grow and
flourish
as one wave helps another wave behind it
when are you
ready to chart the entrepreneurial path
well
maxwell maltz
in his uh
tome which is really a wonderful book
called
psycho cybernetics
said that quote you're ready to do
something when you can
visualize yourself doing it
but there's a relatively short time
window it's somewhere between your age
now and
your mid-30s say
it's sooner rather than later
in percentage terms not many
entrepreneurs start or buy their first
ventures after the age of 40 and the
vast majority
eighty-five percent in a study i saw not
too long ago
the vast majority of first-time
entrepreneurs are pre-thirty-five
remember
that entrepreneurs are just like you and
me
in ability
what they have that is distinctive
is vision
and conviction
remember too that warm sense of
everything going well in your career
may only be the body temperature at the
center of the herd
what are the rewards of the
entrepreneurial path
at the top of my list would be freedom
to stretch my capabilities
to put my imprimatur on a company to
create something to have an ethical
impact on others
and to have financial independence
now i know that it is
unfashionable even day class a
to talk about money
within the academy
money is a byproduct we all say with our
noses firmly in the air
we do well will be paid
well here's a comment about money that i
offer without apology
there's a big difference between being
rich
and being wealthy
being rich is having money
being wealthy
is having money
and
time
the fundamental difference
between income and capital
financial independence when you're young
enough to enjoy it may be something
worth working for
it gives you an opportunity to have a
second career and a third career
and to be psychologically able to set
out
in a new direction
and thus if you stay with a successful
business you've created you do it out of
choice
not necessity
it helps as a prospective entrepreneur
to have the ability to read people and
within reason to predict behavior
it's important to cover the critical
skills
of the business that you're going into
the value drivers
either alone or with a partner
it helps to have an experienced deal
lawyer at your side
it's essential to maintain one's
reputation
and the highest standards of behavior
because as you well know
it takes years to build a reputation
but only a trice
only one act
to lose it
and once you tell a lie
everything else you ever say to that
person is brought into question
it's also important to control your
anger
to speak more softly
and slowly
as you get more upset
it's desirable to minimize your enemies
because burning bridges
is only an indulgence
and bring along a healthy respect for
others
all others
one of the memories i have of
high school
is that is a 10th grade algebra class
and we sat down to a test
and the class was working through the
test as was i
we got to the last question of the test
it was about a 40-minute test and the
last question itself was worth 20
of the whole test
and the woman who taught the class
had asked as that question
what is the name of the janitor who
cleans the room
none of us knew the answer
it was december we'd been there three
months none of us knew the answer
we saw the janitor every day
we didn't have the respect
to speak to him and learn his name
there's a confluence of the ethical and
the practical in life
so i ask you to resolve to take the high
road
and in your quest
pause now and then to ease the burdens
of your fellow travelers
you know it's been said
that we all go through life
with partly broken hearts
any definition of a successful life
must include service to others
we've all drunk from wells we didn't dig
i reject the prevailing notice notion
that the pursuit of selfishness
has overtaken the possibility of
compassion and i ask you to reject it as
well
not just by giving
a few hundred dollars to your local
charity or taking a titular position on
the hospital board
but by devoting your time and your
skills to something worthwhile
to really pull on the oars and make a
difference
in areas where you are qualified to do
so
here
the evocative words of the magnificent
17th century metaphysical poet george
herbert
in his brief piece entitled
virtue
sweet day
so cool
so calm
so bright
the bridle of the earth and sky
the dew shall weep thy fall tonight
for thou must die
sweet rose
whose hue angry and brave bids the rash
gazer wipe his eye
thy root is ever in its grave
and thou must die
sweet spring
full of sweet days and roses a box where
sweets compacted lie
my music shows ye have your closes
and all must die
only a sweet and virtuous soul
like seasoned timber
never gives
but though the whole world
turned to coal
then
chiefly lives
at the end of my days i do not want the
devil
the foot man
to snicker and hold my coat
if i have led well
and stood for something
i think i won't have to worry
you know at this school
we teach you lots of things we know
you'll soon forget
because we don't know
how to teach you what you'll always need
to know
compassion
commitment
concern
involvement
and love
i submit that the saddest phrase of
middle age is
i wish i had
how much better to be able to say
with open eyes i have dared
and cherish no regrets
it's undeniably tougher to create your
own opportunity than to be part of
someone else's
but i've been down the entrepreneurial
road and it offers unparalleled
exhilaration
if you choose to take that road
ignore the naysayers
because very likely your only supporters
will be other entrepreneurs and those
with blind faith in you
so do it if you will
my confidence is in your minds
and in your imaginations
and in your convictions
and finally these words of robert frost
which my students have heard before
i shall be telling this with a sigh
somewhere ages and ages hence
two roads
diverged in the wood and i
i took the one
less traveled by
and that's made all the difference
end quote
thank you
you